إنها نيجيريا والجزائر
حيث تتأذى الأخبار حتى ليبيا
إذا كان هذا هو الحب من النظرة الأولى
محركات tce البلوط في كل مكان
في ساحة الخردة للأسرة تمكنت من العثور عليها
وضربت المال وأنا في مقاطعته
في غامبيا وحصلت على حريتي و
كل صباح وفيانا ويعطينا
الهاتف وفقًا لما تقوله إذا كان لديك
ترقص وربما الخسارة لهذا
ليس ضمنيًا ستبدأنا
الكتابة تجعلنا في المنزل حقًا
يطير حول الموضوع ليس فقط
هذه حادثة أعلى بكثير من
الأسقف لعدد ستة من الصعب السفر
ners الغينيون يرون أنه أقل من ذلك
مولينز الذي يتحدث إليك في هدية هذا
لم يكن سهلا حتى المضخات
الراحة التي وجدناها المال
حاولت العبور
[موسيقى]
أربع مرات
ثالث قوي لسنا مستحقين
السنة الثالثة مرة كان
كارثة عشناها من خلال المشاهد
مدهش في مؤيد نقطة
حتى ليد مثل هذا هو
الكثير من الشجاعة لأنها كذلك
حقًا لم نفكر حقًا
البقاء أثناء القيادة لأنها
التقاط وتشغيل ذاكرة الوصول العشوائي يفعل ذلك
ألم في القلب
ولكن في وقت مبكر جدا من صباح es8 طريقة
تدرب على أن تأخذ ويبدأ
كل الشعب الذي كان عليه
القارب لأنه يمكننا جميعًا أن نحلم و
ترى القوباء المنطقية عند الأمواج
ارتدى الجمهور دائرة الأبراج التي تستحقني
إطار رسومات الأشخاص الذي يعمل
بلان قبره هو إنسان
فقط
ليبيا لم تعد هكذا
ما زلنا نقضي الليل تحت الماء
يوم بعد حفلة حيث طلب هولو
صباح اليوم رأينا امرأة تعرفهم
مات في روديا لا أعرف
إذا كانت المجاعة ست سنوات غرق
كانت الليلة التي كنا فيها هناك في الاسم
لم تتح له الفرصة للعيش هناك
الآن و غدا
الآن 15 سنة غير مرحب به
أنقذنا هذه المباريات القادمة
أن يكون لي منصب آسف أنا
الذين لديهم مناصب قليلة ويروننا
حسنًا ، كيف يعمل الرصاص
التعذيب أو حيث يأتي لإنقاذنا
والإحصاءات إلى الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة Ford He
بدلا من ذلك تسمي ليبيا التعليمية
الآن مرة لأنه يحدث له
مشاهدة ليس كل شيء بدون
صوت عند إطلاق سراحها بعد قاربها
منا لإنقاذنا من كبار السن
جاك السيارات غبي كل الناس الذين
كانوا بجانبه فلنقع فيه
الماء
كل نفسي ذهب كامل تحت
فقدت جيرسي بسبب تلقي النوم
صديق نشاركه و حلو نحن
قال من جميع أبحاثنا كانت
القمامة الحالية ولكن مدى ذلك
يقترح أحد اثنين من الأسلحة المميزة و
فصلتنا إيطاليا
كما يسأل كل شيء
الحكومات في جميع أنحاء العالم الاتحاد
أوروبي أكثر دقة إذا كنت
يرجى بذل كل جهد ممكن لإرسالهم
قوارب في البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​لأننا
نحن المهاجرين عبر الإنترنت
كنا نعتمد على وإلا فإننا لا نعول
لا تهتم بالحسابات بالتفصيل
البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​هدفنا هو المزيد
بناء عليها وليس ذلك قال جزء جيد
من ليبيا عادوا حصلوا على المزيد
كم المدة التي
لأنه عندما يكون لنا الليبي
خد سلحفاة gaudiot مرات أكثر من قبل
تقرير لما كان يحدث رئيس السوبر
في الصحافة الرفيق العزيز
لنكن حذرين لأن البحر الأبيض المتوسط
ليس مكانًا ممتعًا